things are going to suck sometimes no
matter what you're never going to avoid
that one thing that I'm particularly
good at is I'm very good at like
changing my mind about things I don't
get too attached to aspects of my
identity I don't feel committed to like
oh this is how people see me so I need
to behave that way I think I've been
good throughout my life of like being
willing to look at myself and be like
well maybe I'm not an author maybe I
just like had a good book I'm very proud
of that and it's obviously a very
important part of my life but I don't
necessarily see that as who I am what do
you see as who you are or do you avoid
that kind of statement I avoid that
statement interesting so that you don't
get trapped yes I'm an author right now
and if at one day it stops being useful
being an author I will stop being an
author